et pour en parler nous sommes avec
gérard vespière il est fondateur du site
le monde décrypté chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen orient
bonjour à vous j'ai envie de dire merci
d'être avec nous et france
alors en quoi cet accord de paix il est
symbolique pour vous écouter h et dans
le gras philosophie de la diplomatie des
petits pas donc cher à henri kissinger
il ya quelques dizaines d'années a donc
nous avons eu l'accord entre l'israël
les émirats arabes unis maintenant donc
le bahreïn à cela donne des perspectives
nouvelles
vis-à-vis du moyen-orient ceci est un
niveau d'analysé l'autre niveau
d'analysé temps de regarder le très
court terme est donc le premier accord
était un peu plus de 70 jours à des
élections américaines à ce nouvel accord
est un peu plus de 50 jours donc il y a
effectivement aussi à des intérêts
politiques domestiques ou aux états unis
1 tout comme des avancées positives pour
netanyahou qui étant certaines
difficultés face à aulas lectorat
israélien est ce que ça veut dire aussi
que l'étau se resserre pour de l'iran à
la bête noire de washington
est ce que c'est cette normalisation que
l'on observe c'est partie de la
stratégie régionale à de donald trump
qui vise à contenir à l'iran ça ne nuit
pas disons ce n'est absolument pas
essentiel il s'agit pas de ligue et à
des pays israël contre l'iran
à chacun sa vision et son autonomie
diplomatique extérieur à mais cela crée
un climat a effectivement positif à au
tour donc de la politique américaine qui
est de d'aider le peuple iranien a
évolué vis-à-vis de ce régime est
peut-être à jouera à se dresser de façon
importante compte le régime des
ayatollahs et cela va être
s'ils se transforme en parallèle avec la
baisse de l'image de l'iran dans le
fameux et célèbre arc chiite de beyrouth
à sanaa au yémen en passant par bagdad
où depuis maintenant un an un an et demi
on entend des cris iran dehors donc
affaiblissement de l'iran à l'intérieur
affaiblissement de l'arc chiite est
effectivement à une certaine diplomatie
convergentes de 2,7 aux états arabes
avec israël alors justement
jusqu'ici seule l'egypte et la jordanie
avait reconnu l'existence de l'état
d'israël comment interprétez-vous cette
normalisation avec les émirats arabes
unis et bahreïn
aujourd'hui écoutés comme je l'évoquais
la stratégie des petits pas ce n'est pas
le deal du siècle n'est ce pas inventé
par la diplomatie américaine a pour
régler le conflit israélo-palestinien à
les saoudiens ont été très clair il
s'agit de pouvoir donner naissance
officiellement à un état un palestinien
digne de ce nom
donc il y à des avancées a qui prennent
du temps
les accords avec la jordanie et l'egypte
n'est ce pas remonte à pratiquement 40
ans donc voilà on a besoin au
moyen-orient de temps pour faire à
avancer fondamentalement le règlement de
ce dossier
qu'est ce qui peut pousser les
monarchies du golfe a signé ces accords
est ce qu'elles se sentent affaibli sur
le plan sécuritaire ça peut être l'une
des raisons
je ne crois pas je crois que ce tas
j'attends réalisme n'est ce pas il n'y a
pas eu de positions entre l'iran et
israël deux points de vue fondamental a
du temps du shah donc il y à une petite
quarantaine d'années les relations et
était tout à fait apaisée donc que ce
sont les ayatollahs de téhéran qui ont
en lancer ce défi vis-à-vis
d'israël qui ont lancé un défi en en
nommant les gardiens de la révolution à
travers leur département international
pour ce quad donc ici jérusalem a pour
visée à au renversement
donc voilà c'est ce régime iranien qui a
créé plus de déstabilisation qu'autre
chose et les régimes arabes et bien
prennent je dirais le temps est le tempo
de l'existence actuelle de l'existence
du siècle de la technologie des flux
financiers des intérêts commerciaux qui
sont effectivement important de des deux
côtés du monde - du moyen-orient est-ce
que c'est naïf de penser que ces accords
peuvent avoir un impact sur les
négociations de paix
israélo-palestiniennes
évidemment je pense que cela va dans le
sens du dialogue dont on a besoin
dont les palestiniens et israël ont
évidemment besoin à pourra stabiliser la
situation
donc c'est une stratégie effectivement
des petits pas ah mais le grand pas à
franchir et l'entrée en négociation
entre israël et la cisjordanie pour
pouvoir mettre en place une paix durable
il faudra en venir là donc ça va prendre
quelques semaines quelques mois quelques
années
peu importe l'échelle du temps mais la
discussion autour du tapis vert est
inéluctable
merci à vous gérard et r je rappelle que
vous êtes fondateur du site le monde
décrypté chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen orient
merci à vous